übrigens in der schweiz haben
rechtspopulisten schon viel länger
erfolg als im rest von europa trotzdem
kann man vor schweiz dann einfach keine
angst haben finde ich habe mir sogar
eine eingeladen hazel bruder meine damen
und herren es so schön ist dann ist
ja
was mich interessieren würde wie schätzt
du als schweizerin als außenstehende die
lage in der eu gerade ein berührt
schweizer sowas überhaupt ne also mich
ob das alles eigentlich überhaupt nicht
die schweiz hat schon seit jahrzehnten
eine solide rechtskonservative partei
und dagegen können diese ganzen eu
pfadfinder feine eigentlich einpacken
hat die schweiz nahmen auch nicht jetzt
erst wieder mit dem nationalismus
angefangen wo die leute den shop vom
zweiten weltkrieg langsam überwunden
haben der zweite weltkrieg oder wir auf
schweizerdeutsch heißt er wäre krieg
danke für das gold nein also für mich
ist das auch immer eine beleidigung wenn
ich höre dass sie afd sich die
schweizerische volkspartei zum vorbild
nimmt weil unsere rechten sind halt
einfach viel professioneller da kann so
ein unorganisierter alu kaufen nicht
mithalten
aber wie wie kann das denn sein dass die
schweiz zu fast einem drittel
rechtskonservative es ihr geld doch
immer so als neutral und vor allem net
ja die leute interpretieren dass er mal
aus nettigkeit die schweizer sind so
höflich und sohn etwa und diese direkte
demokratie wie nett und dann noch der
dialekt wie nett dabei haben die
schweizer einfach keine eier zumal
unmöglich zu sein
deswegen ist die schweizer auch neutral
weil es einfach keine helvetische
führungspositionen gibt die
charismatisch und leidenschaftlich genug
wäre um zum beispiel mal einen genozid
zu starten
zum beispiel wie soll man sich denn auch
vorstellen seinen schweizer faschismus
wer sollte das denn überhaupt machen wir
haben gar niemanden der rhetorisch fit
genug wäre um die massen in allen vier
landessprachen zu begeistern
dann würde der schweizer diktator sofort
volk stehen und sagen hallo also holler
voller kann so schön dass sie alle fünf
gekommen sehen
also wir haben uns überlegt dass wir die
anderen völker nichts zu suchen finden
weil sie sehen ein bisschen komisch aus
sie sind so ein bisschen dunkelrot und
das gefällt uns nicht also ein paar von
ihnen sind sogar noch heraus wir das
finden wir eigentlich sogar noch
gruseliger sie riechen irgendwie
speziell und das treppenhaus riecht
schon um 10 uhr 30 noch zwiebeln wenn
sie kochen ich meine ganz ehrlich wer
braucht schon um 10 uhr 30 zwiebeln es
ist einfach irritieren und deswegen
haben wir uns überlegt dass wir die
anderen völker es gerne hätten wollen
also nur wenn sie auch lust und zeit
haben ein okay gut an
danke
schilling
das würde niemals funktionieren und ich
bin ja auch froh darum eigentlich also
ich bin froh um jeden menschen der sich
nicht traut sein innerstes böses
auszuleben da mache ich innerlich
freudensprünge der das ist natürlich
übertrieben wie gesagt ich bin
schweizerin wir haben keine emotionen
wir haben geld immerhin okay okay aber
gut aber wenn ich das richtig verstehe
dann sagst du die eu müsste zur
rechtspopulismus abwehr einfach auch
viel höflicher werden nein das ist zu
viel höflichkeit finde ich eigentlich
auch nicht gut da wird man dann
unentspannt ich merke schon auch das
meiner höflichkeit mich manchmal selber
einschränkt also ich habe oft angst dass
ich in unangenehmen situationen gebracht
werde einfach weil ich nicht nein sagen
kann
meine größte angst ist dass ich mal aus
höflichkeit heroinabhängig werde ich so
nachts am bahnhof warte und dann kommt
so eine magere desillusionierte
irgendwie leer blickende aber trotzdem
leicht liebenswürdige zitternde track
nutzer auf mich zu und bietet mir heroin
an schwanz nicht warum man truck load
halloween mit sich führen würde aber
vielleicht hat ja einen
volkshochschulkurs besucht du musst
deinen markt erweitern ab was und
downloads anbieten und dann bietet sie
mehr heroin und dann sage ich nicht nein
das ist so wie wenn man an ostern bei
der oma ist und sie bietet das dritte
stück kuchen an und man will mega keinen
kuchen mehr aber sind ihre letzten
ostern hazel warm und hell
[Applaus]